okay
all right i think it's working now it
got weird on me i like tried to start
the stream it was like live streaming
it's not available right now and i was
just the hell but i think i think i
think i'm live now
folks will let me know i'm sure
uh hey folks yeah um i can't speak for
uh for gozer or for pirates uh carowind
won't be joining us today
um
i mean the the the bi-weekly um streams
haven't been too intense i think i can
manage on my own uh without without the
mods or hopefully some will show up
later but i i think i think i think
we'll live
um
i hope everybody's doing well
so um
reminder at the top i will do my best to
keep up with the chat um best way to get
my attention well at the one thing that
will guarantee that you
that my
that you are seen by me and my eyes uh
is to do a super chat which will also
get you a heart from me i'm being a
little weird with this finger because i
just put nail polish on it
um
that will guarantee that i will see and
reply to whatever you put up um not
doing that at me i'll be more likely to
see it but i make no promises there's
also the discord um which is accessible
to folks who are patreon supporters do
be aware if that is you
the question the cutoff for submitting
questions through the discord was the
start of the stream so i'll be looking
at those later on
um but not
immediately and no new questions at this
point well you can ask them i won't
answer them
okay
looking cool i wish like it's it's
supposed to finally cool off tonight
um for the first time in like a week and
a half like two weeks so
you know i'm looking forward to that
um it's just been so hot and sweaty the
rat
the rats have melted they aren't happy
i've actually got i've actually got them
shut up in one of the bedrooms right now
that has air conditioning my office does
not have air conditioning
today's international day of worlds
indigenous people
lovely
well
i'll have a have a sip to that
i've just watched the man in the iron
mask curious if you've seen it what your
opinions of it are if so i did see it
in the theater
when it first came out in
i think the late 90s
i remember thinking it was decent
but too long
but i have not rewatched it since the
90s so i don't know how well i stand by
that opinion
um
bit of a sad week for me my croft my dog
died recently oh
really sorry to hear that
that's great name for a dog though
what time is it where i am it's seven
o'clock in the evening
how's life
life is okay
um i'm finally starting to get caught up
on some stuff
that i've been working on forever
there's there's a video uh there's a
premiere already set up on the vera wild
channel and that is a video that i have
been editing
since february
so
yeah uh it's nice to finally have that
done
um
it was warm enough in dublin to have my
ice cream melt within minutes yeah that
tracks sounds about right uh
did you see how it ends came out last
year it was a strangely uplifting end of
the world flick
no i've lost track of the end of the
world movies because there's like
how it ends or this and this is the end
and the friend at the end of the world
and like they all have very similar
names and there was like a five year
stretch where they just kind of
all came out and i yeah
i haven't seen most of them
i haven't really been in the mood to
watch the world end
i think i get enough of that just
keeping up with the news
supreme omega thank you very much for
the super chat on amphibio do you feel
there should have been more episodes on
sasha and marcy i feel the show uh had
too much focus on the planters and not
enough finance friends
um
i didn't find myself wanting for that
but i don't think it would have hurt the
show to make that decision
um
it's not like i'm uh
it's not like i'm super
uh committed to the idea that like they
were right not to do or they definitely
should i think it would have been a
perfectly fine decision but it wasn't
something i'd found myself missing while
watching it so that's kind of where i am
at it
watch your review of nope earlier today
that's a good movie
nope is a really good movie i feel like
it got undervalued because it seems like
a lot of people felt the need to like
rank jordan peele's three movies and a
lot of them put that at the bottom so
they were like which i think is
underselling it i'm not gonna tell you
where i think it ranks with three movies
because i think that's irrelevant it's a
good movie it's a really good movie
what in my opinion on neil patrick
harris saying the 14th doctor is gonna
be the
gayest doctor ever i forget what his
exact words were i didn't love seeing it
um
and i actually posted on twitter
like
did he just
kind of spoil
ways in which the doctor's actually
going to be played
or did he just um
you know unintentionally out shootie
gotchua who i've talked about before
is not
publicly gay he's not publicly anything
he's never clarified his sexuality so i
don't know which it was i don't love it
either way
i get that you know he was trying to be
enthusiastic and
uh and all that but like
after watching your villain ranking tier
i think you should carry on with the war
doctor
big finish as the dalek time strategist
has the deepest voice of them all
uh
i i should try some more of the word the
problem is i listened to the first
series of the war doctor
and it just really underwhelmed me
i may have made the mistake of listening
to the war master first which is
so much more ambitious and a lot better
can't stay for too long funeral tomorrow
this has been a fun week i mean oh my
goodness i'm really sorry to hear that
ben good grief
i seen prey yet i don't have hulu
so i don't know if i will ever get to
see that
today's also uh katie angel's birthday i
saw that i saw that on tick tock
she was lovely i was glad i got to meet
her at um
at california one
have you seen the 2009 dorian gray film
have you also read the book absolutely
love oscar wilde's writing style i have
neither seen that movie nor read that
book
i think the only oscar wilde thing
i've read is the importance of being
earnest which i do like quite a bit i
like that kind of um
uh
comedy of manners
kind of thing
hey vera i've been uh hearing a lot
about owl house from you and i'm curious
uh what it is i'm pretty sure i heard
that alex hersh is behind it how true is
that statement that true is not that
statement's not true at all logan alex
hirsch does a voice in it of one of the
main recurring characters
and
the actual creator of the thing dana
terrance i believe worked on gravity
falls
so you could say that his style may have
influenced things he is not directly
involved creatively
at all
so if someone's trying to sell it to you
saying this is his show it's not his
voice is very present and like it's hit
like it's it's a very similar voice to
bill cipher which is basically the guy's
normal speaking voice so like you'll get
a sense of his presence
certainly but like creatively no
no it's not his show
surprisingly it's 64 degrees where i
live that fahrenheit or celsius
i i'm assuming that's fahrenheit because
64 celsius is like something ridiculous
i knew the ah that took longer to come
up in the questions than i thought what
do you think about the merger of hbo and
discovery okay i am not going to get
heavily into this right now because this
is the subject of saturday's video so
i'll be going through in a lot more
detail there about what has and hasn't
been going on because as is commonly the
case with a rapidly uh evolving story
there's a lot of people who have either
made faulty assumptions or ran with
information that came out early and
turned out to not quite be true but
they're still assuming that that early
report was correct etc etc etc
short version i don't love it
i don't love what they're doing i do
understand a decent amount of it
some of it i don't
really get
but um
like i can track most of what they say
they're doing
uh let's see
what celebrity have you loved in the
past but lost all respect for or uh
before in an instant because of their
actions i mean jk rowling
would
would be the big one
with the patterns of doctors joining the
mcu who do you think jody whittaker
should play oh
um that's an interesting question
i don't have a
pick off the top of my head
um
it's not all the the mcu it's just
superhero
uh movies in general
because morbius is technically not the
mcu and capaldi was in suicide squad
which is dc i will say though they've
pretty much all been villains
whitaker make an interesting mystique
actually
i know ghostbusters is your favorite
movie of all time yes it is well
remembered i was wondering what some of
your runner-ups might be oh geez
uh
like just too many there's a lot um
the thing is i like i know that number
one slot and stuff other than that it's
just like a
cobbled together
mess and it's all over the place you
know
summer wars
labyrinth
um
another thin man i really like a lot
clue
knives out
that this that's a few for you i could
come up with more but we'll we'll go
with that for right now
supreme mega thank you very much for the
super chat in your trauma video there
are fans who actually like
hal's heel turn nowadays some say hal
was more interesting when he was
parallax inspector thoughts when he was
parallax absolutely not absolutely not
parallax was boring as [ __ ] he was a
generic
powerful i will destroy the universe
parallax was boring
spectre was kind of interesting because
it was a little bit of a redemptive
pattern and like i can be iffy on
redemption stories in general but
like a lot of it was rooted in the idea
that he had truly done some terrible
stuff but also the nature of the sp
spectre
is not a purely heroic figure the
spectre is a violent frightening figure
so it made for an interesting thing that
he was kind of earning redemption
through something that wasn't
a clear-cut paragon sort of role that
was interesting parallax was not
parallax there was nothing interesting
about parallax
ah
moving along cara
watson thank you very much for the
super chat i finished my children's
story last week hovering around 3k words
seems okay for a book with illustrations
i'm struggling with a title though tips
um
i mean
obviously i've never read it so i can't
give you tips on what to actually call
the thing itself if you're asking me for
tips on
what to call it
i mean if there's a main recurring
line motif something if not that
directly something related to that
um
honestly just
give it to some people you trust and say
hey what do you think would make sense
as a title and like just to get some
options
um i recently played through the edge of
reality and to be honest i found it an
enjoyably broken game i'm glad you got
enjoyment out of lu out of it louis i
i had a miserable time absolutely
miserable with that
with that game
i live in georgia my friend i may as
well
read on the state welcome sign
may swamp ass rain down on all
john vinyls thank you very much for the
super chat
hot take incoming oh dear me thinks the
owl house and amphibia will be as iconic
to future generations of disney fans as
the classic renaissance movies are to
our generation
i
yes and no
so
yes in that they will be comp comparably
beloved two things
from our generation
but i don't think the movies is the
right comparison to make because like
simply put the movies are
pretty universally
viewed the shows are more niche that's
true now that was true then so i think
your closer equivalent would be that
they will be as beloved as
ducktales gargoyles
um and sort of thing
darkwing duck maybe things of that
nature
i don't i don't think it's fair to
compare to the movies which are always
going to be seen by way more people in
all honesty i'm ready for the fall i'm
always ready for fall fall is the best
season which actor from modern era
doctor who that has played a companion
in the past would you like to see play
the doctor
um
i'm not
i'm not sure i'd go for any of them to
be completely honest
um
bill maybe pearl mackey
have you seen the film romeo plus juliet
yes the bazlerman yeah it's not bad
especially at the time i thought
actually
for for giving a very 90s energy it was
actually a pretty good uh update and
adaptation of the work for what it was
trying to be it was something that
really connected with young people in a
way that the original play would have at
the time in a way that trying to do that
play straight
which actually kind of did it didn't
alter the dialogue or anything but like
doing it as a period piece wouldn't have
connected with the actual young people
that
it would otherwise appeal to so i
actually thought that was a that was a
pretty good way of doing it
uh and it kicked off a wave of of um
modernized shakespeare stuff which
produced some
results but also it gave us stuff like
titus and 10 things i hate about you so
i'm not going to complain
questions have you read the earth 2
series from dc came out during the new
52 era it's actually really good
especially how they handled alan scott
and jay garrick i never did read those i
heard people liked them i did hear that
i never read them though
did you ever play final fantasy 9 it's
my personal favorite of the 3d final
fantasy games i did play that one
it was good
i enjoyed it um
it felt a little uh kind of retrograde
to me
um and obviously like for some people
that's the appeal of it
but um
i don't know as someone who's all-time
favorite is still final fantasy vi final
fantasy 9
felt like it was grasping for old ideas
without doing much to elevate it
actually for the full 3d i really like
final fantasy 12 which nobody seems to
talk about anymore
which that to me felt like a really
interesting propelling forward of things
while also going back to a simpler
easier to follow story and some of the
things that i did like about six but
while also feeling like the whole thing
wasn't kind of backpedaling
adrenaline thank you so much for the
super chat
hi vera would love your thoughts on sean
bean saying intimacy
coordinator spoil the spontaneity of sex
scenes
okay i wondered if this was going to
come up so
keep in mind that at time of speaking
this is based off a
cursory look at what it was that he said
my read on it
is that he was expressing
an honest opinion about his own personal
discomfort and issues with them in
working environments that he himself is
present in i did not get a vibe from him
that he was railing against the concept
of them existing at all
and everything about what he said to me
read as
so
basically what he said because it wasn't
just it wasn't just spoiled the
spontaneity because if that was all that
he said
i might not hold this opinion but he
also said that having
being watched that closely in what is
meant to be a scene where he's trying to
project intimacy to a camera in an
already artificial setting
made him
very self-conscious and made it
difficult to do his job and i believe
him when he says that i don't think he's
using that as an excuse
i think it genuinely makes
it harder for him
to
focus and do his work now as far as the
spoiled spontaneity that probably is
more to do with how he is used to these
kinds of scenes being played but in
terms of his sense of self-consciousness
i absolutely believe him when he says
that now that puts him in a situation
where there's if that if i'm right and
that's his sincerely held conviction
that it makes his job harder and again i
don't never got the impression he was
speaking for anyone else but if he's
saying like it makes my job harder when
they're here
if that is
what he was trying to express there's
almost no way to express that that isn't
going to get somebody upset because
they're going to oh so you think there
shouldn't be anybody over seeing what
you're doing you think you should be
allowed to do what you want
none of that is what he said
so
the impression that i get is that he was
expressing a
personally held reality
for him as an actor
and
did not think in the moment about how
that
uh how that was going to read when heard
or read by other people that's my
takeaway and impression i never got the
feeling that he was going
we don't need this i should be allowed
to do whatever i want
i never got that i never got that vibe
uh off the answer as i have seen it
so
there there we go
have i played the video game stray nope
i have not
last season of riverdale was good liz
has just started watching that she's
taking notes
she's gonna tell me about it at some
point later and try and break me
oh boy
uh
with the with the exception of gargoyles
aren't those cartoons way deeper than
all 1990s disney cartoons
well yes but i wasn't comparing them in
terms of storytelling style
um the the original question was will
they be as beloved as so i was comparing
the love that the current generation
will have for them not actually
comparing them as products to each other
so i think he kind of misunderstood why
i made that comparison lucy wood thank
you very much for the super chat greatly
appreciated hi council of geeks which
actor or actress who has played the
doctor do you think would be best at
playing the master oh okay so i know
most people's answer to this
is david tennant
because they watched jessica jones
now let's be very clear
kilgrave
was the perfect villain for that and
david tennant played him
amazingly
kilgrave is not the master though and
that is not a way i would want
the master to be played
not to say that i don't think
david tennant could play a good master
but honestly i would rather see capaldi
do it
as far as um
actors
still with us though even that set aside
you know
despite the fact that i don't really
like his doctor that much
something in me says that davison
could make a really interesting master
does america have an equivalent to a
supermarket meal deal for lunch if so
what would you get
uh i mean a lot of supermarkets just
have like pre-made stuff it's usually
it's usually
fried stuff it's usually like fried
chicken and stuff like that i don't i
try not to grab it i do sometimes i
shouldn't though
finally started reading dreams of fire
my uh tbr is way too long i am enjoying
it a lot about 24 and well thank you
cappuccino crafts i hope you enjoy it
all the way through
it feels weird not having gozer uh
heroin and pirates known i know i'm not
sure where pirates or ghosts are i do
know about carolyn like she's she's
she's fine but she won't be joining us
question who uh is a voice actor you
must associate with a specific character
personally tim daly superman roger craig
smith is batman christopher daniel
barnes a spider-man um
okay so
based off the way you were to that
question i'm assuming you're saying like
a character who they weren't the only
one to voice so like i think voice
acting my brain kind of goes to david
keith voicing goliath in uh gargoyles
but
um
like
goliath was never voiced by anyone else
um
uh
[Music]
probably but like i'm suddenly drawing a
huge flipping blank
i don't know why
i mean mark hamill is the joker
specifically the uh the bruce tim joker
they've brought him back to do the joker
again in other settings and it hasn't
worked as well and i don't think it's
because he's become any less good at it
it's because
his
version of the joker was
built around a very specific world to
inhabit and they've tried to drop him
into other ones or like in the freaking
killing joke and that didn't work
just trying to think if i can think of
anybody else
that's just the one kind of leaping to
my oh um
uh cch pounder
uh for
amanda waller oh she's good
riverdale makes me depressed it could
have been a good show if the writing was
better i don't think the writing was
ever good
um
i'm writing a series at the moment that
set in my hometown i doubt i could get
it filmed here
as i'm presenting uh the uk city of
culture
as a bit of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes that would probably make funding a
little tricky to get
but who knows
uh supreme omega thank you once again
for the super chat
uh
an old spidey i get
why norman should have stayed at norman
osborne yet he was a better villain as a
haunting ghost created a legacy of evil
aka the anti-uncle ben yeah he should
have stayed dead
harry should have stayed dead
honestly most of the spider-man
characters who came back should have
stayed dead
uh with harry and norman being the big
ones
thankfully they never really brought
back gwen like they fake did that a
couple times
but they never actually pulled that for
real thank
goodness
oh they brought ben reilly back again
and like they're doing some weird
weird [ __ ] with him i don't know why
i don't know why
uh
i kind of want to watch riverdale
because i've recently discovered i love
zero to bat [ __ ] train wrecks
it might work for you for that yeah
uh did you ever see the 2009 wonder
woman animated film i did i think it's
pretty good you know for a 80-minute
animated film
uh i'm not
i'm not inclined to compare to the gal
gadot movie i think both are good
isn't it a shame that matt smith's first
role in a superhero movie he wasn't
morbius he could have been
amazing in any other role well i still
haven't seen morbius so for all i know
he was amazing in that i don't know it's
morbid time
have you watched last night in soho i
have not it is one of the many things on
my very
very
very long to watch
list uh i hope that sasha dwan sticks
around after jody leaves unlikely
um miss wicked wolf because it's been
announced that he's gonna be involved
with big finish
and while i don't think it's a hard
contract rule as a general rule
they have not gotten access to any of
the actors if those actors are still
appearing in the show
which probably also means we aren't
getting any more of joe martin because
she's gonna start working with big
finish too
so hate to be the one to break it to you
but
uh thoughts on war for the planet of the
apes
um
it was it was pretty good it was a solid
closeout to that series i think it was
the the least good
uh of the of the three of the rebooted
planet of the apes movies
i gotta
stop just swallowing spit the wrong way
uh lucy wood thank you so much for the
super chat when you made your youtube
video sorting the doctors into hogwarts
houses three years ago you said jody
whitaker would be a hufflepuff has your
opinion changed since
oh geez i haven't thought in terms of
hogwarts houses for a long time for
what should be obvious reasons
um
i think probably i'd shift her
uh
over to ravenclaw i think she's a little
bit too emotionally constipated to be a
hufflepuff
i'm not going to think about that
anymore than i already have though so
don't i won't
be pinned down on that but you know
ever watch the americans on fx i never
did i'm familiar with it never did watch
it
uh rather than an unhinged master which
is basically what we've had variants of
a new who i'd like to see and move back
to a more charming erudite portrayal if
you have not listened to the war master
on big finish that will give you what
you are asking for
imagine uh dejuan's
master and missy as a duo i think they
would pull each other apart have you
watched the boys i have not i don't like
garth ennis's writing so i have no
intention of watching the boys
and yes i've had people say to me oh but
like oh it's it's better it's different
i've looked up vague synopsis of what
goes on i'm like no this this is very
garth ennis
like i'm just
maybe it's better executed than he does
when he writes the comics himself but
you know i'm looking at these just
general descriptions and what people say
when they talk about i'm like that
sounds exactly like the guy who's
writing i don't like
did you hear that josh keaton really put
out a video recently put out a video
where he does the monologue from the
amazing spider-man number 121 and holy
hell the man is still got it you know i
don't know who josh keaton is
uh you're gonna have to film me on who
that is logan
uh i think rdt will get rid of
everything chibnall well yes but that's
standard
really none of the showrunners have
kept in place any of the immediate stuff
some of them have brought back stuff
that the other show runners uh had
during their time or introduced during
their time but like they all started
with fairly clean slates that's
yeah i expect so too but it's not
because he hates chibnall stuff it's
because that's what's happened every
time
you know what annoys me most about big
finish the fact that they give you the
month of the release but never the day
if you're trying to keep on top of it
yeah that would be annoying
13th doctor big finish when also uh
would you
want her to meet river in it i i would i
would like her meeting river
did you ever watch the 2004 battlestar
galactica i never did
never did no actually that's not true i
saw a marathon of most of the first
season but that was like
2006 i saw that
and i didn't i didn't go back to it
after that not that i didn't like it but
like i just i didn't like it enough to
like track down the rest of it
um
what star wars villain
do you think would make the best doctor
who villain
jabba
i think jabba would make the best doctor
who villain
cameron h thank you very much for the
super chat
i found your channel because a recent
x-men video got recommended hooked ever
since oh
it is nice to be reassured that every
now and then every now and then the
algorithm does still put my stuff in
front of new people occasionally
uh not
not very often but sometimes
sometimes
uh doctor who villain i kind of want to
see back the taclofane i don't know what
else there is to do about with the taco
fan though like their entire
like they worked i don't think there's
anything wrong with them but like
the thing about the
the talk of fame is that
what makes them work and memorable
is that
they
is is that twist and that reveal of what
they are
with that already out of the way i don't
know if there's much interesting to
actually do with them
ns is too cynical edis is too juvenile
and yeah here's my problem with garth
ennis's writing
yes he's a bit cynical i don't think
that's his core problem though because i
can enjoy cynical writers sometimes
i think the problem is he
he has a very
high school
college
sense of humor
mentality
world worldview and
he's about 70 as clever as he thinks he
is
he is not unclever he's actually
fairly clever
he's not nearly as clever as he thinks
he is and that that 30 gap
grates on me the more i read his stuff i
think the stuff from him that i liked
the best was the punisher because
he was trying
it seemed like the least to say
something with the punisher he seemed to
focus on just telling a decent story so
like um
welcome welcome back frank and um
and born we're both pretty decent i
think partially because he wasn't trying
to reinvent the wheel or to make a big
statement
which is stuff that he has tried to do
with things like preacher and the boys
and i just really don't i really don't
care for his stuff um outside of the
punisher stuff that i mentioned because
i've read some of his other punisher
stuff other than that and he also went
off the rails there too but at least for
a little while he was a good fit for the
punisher
josh keaton is the voice of spider-man
from the spectacular spider-man series
oh cool i never watched that one
uh who would you put in a doctor who
suicide squad i mean individuals
okay so ooh
so the whole premise of the suicide
squad
is
disposable villains
like that's the whole idea
but like who could actually get
some work done
so um
see the thing is most of the one-off
villains
from doctor who they tended to like
maybe they they had a decent bit of tech
or you know going for them but they
don't a lot of them don't have actual
powers or anything like that
um
trying to think
because like it's a really good idea and
i'm kind of i'm
i'm fumbling because it's it's an idea
that deserves a good answer
and my brain is kind of cycling
trying to come up
with uh with something with anything
on that um
i mean like disregard the fact that some
of these
most of these characters would just flat
out be dead but um
daleksec the hybrid daleksec
uh that'd be a good addition i think
that one would make sense
um
dr lazarus could be the muscle um
in addition to that
uh the wire
could be the hacker
[Laughter]
like let let's go let's go fully with
the suicide squad because they're also
supposed to be kind of crap villains
that's one of the problems with putting
like harley quinn on the suicide squad
is like she's a good villain people like
her whereas the heart of the suicide
squad is like there's these are supposed
to be crap villains that nobody actually
likes that much
um
yeah i feel like i should toss at least
one more on there
um
they can have a cyber shade as the
mascot
uh i don't know if you're aware of this
but the doctor who movie you reviewed
uh the other was panned at the time does
that surprise you not especially
um
i wasn't aware because like if i'm gonna
watch something regardless what the
critical consensus is doesn't matter too
much to me
felicity keen thank you very much for
the super chat will you be making a
video about the batgirl film sort of the
video that i'm coming out with on
saturdays about
kind of the whole scope
of the warner brothers discovery
all this crap going on um it initially
was supposed to just be about batgirl
but then the whole thing snowballed um
so yeah that that will be wrapped up in
uh in that video where i'll be covering
a fair bit of stuff
i hope at some point in doctor who every
single doctor that's come before teams
up with the new doctor in a final fight
i mean i think the closest we got to
that
that we'll ever get was day of the
doctor
and i think it would be hard to try and
do that again without it just feeling
like
that all over again hey vera what do you
think of my solution to the magneto
problem i have him be in the holocaust
and then jump forward through time like
captain america
that
can work
personally
uh for me for my feeling on magneto i
would rather have him here
and present and having witnessed
humanity backslide i think
you can still like get him to the same
place if he leaps forward in time and
he's like things aren't better but i
think to truly bring out the bitterness
or the sense of i have to do something
because nothing's gonna get better
otherwise is if he has been here
seen the post-war era
seen things start to head in a better
direction and then backslide i think
that
would resonate with that character
stronger for me and the way i like
him uh if poison ivy makes an appearance
in suicide squad three or birds of
parade two karen gillian could play her
that'd be an interesting pick
uh
what would you think of doctor who
taking a break from the master and
bringing back a different time lord not
the ronnie
because we know your thoughts maybe the
monk or romano i'd be out for the monk
uh big finish has done some fun stuff
with the monk so i'd be down for that
uh oh captain omni once more thank you
so very much
um i've seen some claim tarzan is a
racist character despite him not really
adopting any of the local culture and
not
being literally raised by apes do you
think people are reading too much into
things um
um
all right hang on
tarzan is a racist character in so much
as he fits a
[Music]
um
a trope and a format that is inherently
white supremacists
now
some people might very well be banging
the drum too hard on that because there
are lots of things that like
fit the mold and the tropes and exist in
the shadow of
um
racism white supremacy colonialism etc
but are not actively pushing any of
those ideas but because they still exist
in those spaces they still carry them
with them so like i'll get to tarzan in
a second but like my go-to example of
that is something like indiana jones
indiana jones
and anything like that any kind of
treasure-hunting archaeological movie
where a white person
goes to a foreign land and basically
grave robs and it's treated like a good
thing is inherently colonialist in its
mentality it's almost never brought up
that the locals
have a claim to whatever it is this
person is getting it's theirs because
finders keepers for some reason or
whatever
so
and i love the indiana well i love two
of the indiana jones movies but and i
don't think that they push that idea
particularly hard but it's ingrained in
the genre similarly with tarzan tarzan
is inherently
a
white supremacist and colonialist
character
in that he is an embodiment of the idea
of if you take like don't forget that
not only is he a white dude he's a lord
so it's this idea that if you take
a white dude from england
drop him in the middle of
the jungle even if he doesn't know
english and is raised by
wildlife
he is going to naturally become
a leader a formidable he will fit in he
will
be able to do everything that the locals
even if those locals are wildlife are
able to do just as well as them if not
better it's a variant on the white
savior um archetype now that can sound
weird with tarzan because he's rarely
directly a savior figure but it's these
are married concepts the
the um inherent colonialism and white
supremacy in white savior narratives is
of a kind with what goes on in something
like tarzan so he carries with him a lot
of colonialist and yes racist baggage
because of the type of story he's in
i haven't actually read any of the
tardis his story so i don't know how
hard
those do or don't push any of those
notions directly
there's a nice long-winded answer for
you
have you ever heard of andrew tate i
feel like i've heard that name don't
know where
so for some confusing reason a lot of
tech billionaires are culture fans do
they need to read surface detail
particularly the vepr stuff
to know what banks think of them um
the thing is is that
people who have won
uh whether it be tech billionaires or
presidents of the united states or
what have you or you know the
you know whatever they will always
picture themselves
as
the good people
in any story even when there is a very
clear analog to them that is very much
not
the good people and vepers is a really
good example of that
it would actually like i'm about
i said i'm about
60 65
of the way through the book now it's a
long damn book um
but i remember early on
with led edger
realizing that
the wrongs that had been done to her by
by veper she was not going to be able or
she was going to not be assisted and
possibly be prevented we'll see where it
goes i haven't gotten to the end yet and
just trying to meet out justice for what
was done to her
because he is too rich and important and
even people who even societies that
recognize oh yes he's terrible
but he's too important
too much of the society pivots on him
we can't just let you go after him it's
too big a domino to let fall
it's kind of the same principle by which
the banks got bailed out
after the financial crisis in 2008 that
they caused
because no matter whose fault it was and
it was their [ __ ] fault
these trees were too big to let fall
they were rotten trees through and
through
they were nothing but a burden but if
they just fall they are going to
demolish whatever's in their wake and
they were very big trees
it's the same principle and yeah reading
that was like oh god i wish that didn't
read so damn true
uh
the less said about temple of doing the
better yeah i really don't care for
temple of doom like at all
yeah i think if tarzan avatar is
actually quite a relatable film you know
being the white guy who came in and
[ __ ] everything up for the natives
yeah
yeah okay um it's quarter two which
means i gotta pop over to the discord
and address any questions asked there so
um i will be back
in hopefully five to ten minutes we'll
see how many questions there are i don't
know um reminder the uh the council of
geeks discord is exclusively a perk of
supporting me on patreon so patreon.com
council of geeks check that out
uh have you gotten to any of netflix's
the sandman yet any thoughts um i am
halfway through
i finished up episode five last night
excuse me and um
so that means i've i've covered
basically all the way through
almost all the way through their
adaptations of the first volume
um
i am liking it a lot better than i
thought it would i'll talk about this
when i actually review the whole thing
but the the marketing really put a lot
of emphasis on how much they were
directly translating in the comic and
that actually made my interest go way
down
um but it's actually very well adapted
and i've been having a really good time
seeing what has been changed and
with only one exception so far to the
changes i've seen all of them being
changes that are at worst neutral and
often interesting like they don't worsen
the story they don't weaken the story
maybe they were necessitated by
something other than narrative or
whatever but they've they've been
interesting adaptational choices with
only one that i'm like nah you shouldn't
have done that but i'm not going to say
what that is here because that would be
spoilery
uh answer me these three answer me these
questions three what's your favorite
comfort food probably macaroni and
cheese halloween or yule slash christmas
um
probably christmas cause i really like
gifts um you have access to the entire
catalog of mutants from the x titles
what mystique story do you tell and why
okay so dharma knows me
pretty well
clearly um
i mean like my default is to is to kind
of pick up with what brian k vaughan did
with the whole thing of of mystique
being
um very black ops uh kind of thing um
outside of that i actually i would like
to put her very front and center
as a as the face of a civil rights
movement
and
what i think i'd build through that is
that she's actually she stopped
the shape-shifting
she just presents herself as is
she goes out she marches she gives
speeches she's she's becoming at the
forefront of these um
of the of the fight for mutant rights
but nobody trusts her because they know
who she is and what she has done and
what she can do no matter what she does
they still won't trust her and to see
how that
wears on her and to see where that would
take her i would be interested to
explore
um
do you think wilf's character will get a
proper send-off in the 60th i don't know
because something i have tried really
hard to confirm and i have not been able
to is whether or not he finished filming
all of his stuff
uh at the time when uh bernard cribbens
passed away and i can't confirm i think
he did but i cannot confirm that
um
i don't think
um i don't think he'll get a send-off in
so far as i do not expect that they will
like add something in the
narrative to like cover the the idea
that he's gone
um i think they'll put a
dedicated to or in memory of at the end
and otherwise leave the narrative alone
uh do you think it's a problem that when
you get lesbian couples in fiction
especially kids fiction they tend to
make them
butch and femme uh like loose is more
tomboyish and amity or korra
or cor is more tomboyish than asami i
mean i think it's a question of degree
i like
yes loose is more tomboyish than amity
but anthony's also not especially girly
um she's not
uh overly femme
so
i i think it's a matter of degree
because i think like unless you
basically stamp out two versions of the
same character you're gonna get some
degree of variance and i think that's
fine as long as you're not doing the
like the far end version of like
of you know so butch and so fam that it
basically fits the
format of what's normally thought of as
a male in a female relationship just
with two girls as long as you're not
going that far and even that you can do
but just be really careful about it i
think
would be it for that
uh does the fact that most young people
in the u.s support queer people make you
at all optimistic that if the right uh
try to do something
uh try to do some
[Music]
uh really bad stuff to lgbtq people next
time they get into federal power there
will be popular resistance to it earlier
today i was listening to a podcast about
the warsaw uprising and the host made
the point that nazis were able to do
what they did uh was because regular
germans even the ones who weren't
particularly anti-semitic just didn't
care about jews enough to help them
resist their persecution as it ramped up
maybe i'm being naive but i would like
to think a lot of straight millennials
and zoomers wouldn't act the same way if
queer people were under similar threat
honestly
i was having this conversation with liz
uh while we were on a hike
i just
i really don't mean
for this to come across as aegis but i
really need
nearly i'd say about 90
of all the boomers in politics to step
down
like
now
especially on the left
because
the
what what is actually cared about and
what is what people what my generation
in general and gen z are passionate
about is flat out not represented in the
us in politics right now because
people in their 60s and up have clung to
power for the last
40 goddamn years
and
it's
it's really become infuriating
i
as far as the right going against queer
people
how well they're able to do that depends
on how well our
our institutions hold
because if the system is not
deliberately broken
and replaced with fascism which
so far has not happened but is not
impossible so long as that does not
happen
the institutions as we have them make
the kind of discrimination
against any group such as queer people
very difficult to sustain
you can get it put in place but like jim
crow before it the fundamental uh
unfairness of it
is going to eventually collapse under
the weight of
the safeguards that are in place far too
slowly like let's
let me be clear
the
revocation and the restriction of these
rights should not be able to happen in
the first place and and me even saying
that so long as the system isn't
deliberate doesn't you know get
completely broken and disassembled then
the system will correct this that is not
a reason to do nothing that's actually
kind of [ __ ] because the system should
be preventing these laws from ever being
put into place but that's a very
american thing we don't try and prevent
bad things we let bad things happen and
then try and fix it later that's an
incredibly american mentality i think
best exemplified by the fact of how we
handle product recalls in this country
you try and introduce a brand new
product into europe you have to go
through all these tests all these
strenuous things to prove that it is not
harmful to consumers and that it does
what you say will do
in america you can bring any goddamn
product to market and it will only be
challenged if
it starts hurting people and evidence
builds of that you don't have to prove
it isn't harmful other people have to
prove that it is and that is very core
to the american mentality and that in
and of itself is a big part of the
problem of where we are right now i've
gone off let's move on
so i just started watching season three
of the boys and it got me wondering if
what if superman was evil as an
overplayed trope yes it is um
overly sarcastic uh productions did a
really good
kind of ramble on that like in my
opinion what if someone tried to do good
and make things worse because he doesn't
know everything would be much more
interesting subversion because i think
uh it's what would actually happen if
you gave a non-sociopath superpowers i'd
actually agree with that that would be a
much more interesting i think a much
more interesting question than what if
superman was evil was what if superman
tried to be good but it made things
worse anyways
i think that's a much more interesting
question because the instant super the
instant you make superman evil he's not
superman anymore because much more than
his strength or his heat vision or his
ability to fly or anything else superman
is defined by
doing the right thing
by
being righteous and just that's who he
is he is he does not turn evil that's
why anyone going what if he was evil
okay then he's not superman you're doing
something else and it's uninteresting
okay i am now back in the main chat
thank you very much for your patience oh
we got some more
uh captain omni thank you again very
much
uh if there was to be a replacement for
the superhero genre in film would you
say sword and sorcery franchises such as
conan the mar the barbarian
or el rick of mel uh mel
melebone
i never knew how to pronounce that is a
good replacement if not why i think
so
honestly the main
problem there
um
comparatively is that
they're
and i'm not saying this doesn't exist
but i'm going by public perception
i don't think that at present the public
perceives that there is as much variety
in
uh high fantasy
as there is in superheroes because you
know you can do
a more sci-fi hero a more fantasy hero
you can do an anti-hero you can do a
paragon hero you know you have a decent
amount of variety
i think the public perception of what
fantasy high fantasy stories are is a
lot more homogeneous and i think it
would take
not just one it would take several
prod
projects to really kind of break that i
think you i'd like i think you'd need to
successfully adapt
like a discworld book but also
successfully
adapt
um you know something like conan the
barbarian or elric or successfully adapt
um like a dress durden book or something
like i think you'd have to you need like
within a five-year span a variety of yes
they're all fantasy
but they're all doing different things
and saying different things
that's what they would all have to be
successful that's what it would take
to be a proper replacement
um is it impossible no i don't think
it's super likely though because i think
to most people fantasy means lord of the
rings
um there was a time when it would have
been fantasy means lord of the rings or
game of thrones but unless house of the
dragon like completely revives people's
interest uh nobody really cares about
game of thrones anymore
sorry
that ending really really botched it
all right we're going to be wrapping up
relatively soon
super chat supreme omega was crisis a
mistake because it resulted in
continuity issues with donatron legion
also made dc try and fix their universe
with more reboots i don't think crisis
was a mistake in
concept i think there were some
execution issues
um with crisis and you've already
highlighted some in terms of uh
continuity with donna troy or the legion
there wasn't great
like people who weren't around at the
time you know hear about crisis and
they're like oh and they rebooted it and
then all these things started over like
there was actually a weird period of a
year or two where it was super unclear
what was or was not in continuity
because the communication
just between the the writers or the
different editors wasn't great and then
it wasn't especially good
um
to the to the readers either so i think
there were some execution issues with
crisis i don't think it was a mistake
though
because
you know speaking of someone who was
always more into marvel than dc
the idea of these multiple continuities
was part of what put me off trying to
catch up with dc
and like by the time i was getting into
comics like the multiverse had been over
for ages but like you would go to comic
shops and they'd still have these these
volumes of this older stuff this
pre-crisis stuff i just look on a shelf
and like see two different versions of
superman and be like what the hell heck
with this where's spider-man um so i
don't think they were wrong to do it i
think there were some issues with it and
i think
they i i don't think crisis was a
mistake i think the new 52
was a mistake
across the board
we're the type of country who will bomb
another country into oblivion then come
in with sandwiches and coffee yeah yeah
that's very america if you got your
hands on a tardis where would you go
first and
uh would you model the console on your
own design or one from the show
uh honestly i feel like i would have the
console set up like a random generator
where i could just hit a button it would
reshuffle and i just keep hitting that
until i got something i liked
still waiting for owl house season three
aren't we all well we're not getting
season three we're getting specials but
uh given that banks wrote the book in
2010 do you think that was intentional
uh he was
trying to criticize how untouchable the
rich seemed at the time
if surface detail was written in 2010
then i would say almost definitely
because given the financial crisis in
2008 and the fact that that was like my
go-to example to compare
um how vepers is treated uh with the
whole idea of too big to fail yeah i
would be shocked if that wasn't
intentional with those books
little big would make a great movie the
visuals are so unique that
that would be really really hard to
adapt to a movie
i'd rather see that done as a as a as a
mini series
i think you'd have much better luck
um
captain omni oh couple from you um
personally i'd say we've got a solid 40
years before the superhero craze dies
down if only because we barely scratched
the surface of the main ones i
disagree i'd say we're probably looking
more in the neighborhood of 10 to 20
years
um
if only because like i don't think
interest in superheroes is going to wane
because they've gone through all the
material i think interests by the movie
going public in superheroes is going to
wane long before it becomes a matter of
but there's still characters to adapt we
don't care i think i think audiences
will move on before they run out of
material
uh oh another one
a hawkman and hot girl being from the
planet thanagar and the silver age is
more interesting than they reincarnation
from the golden age they keep pushing
flash gordon-style alien warriors are
cooler i'm inclined to agree the the the
reincarnation thing it wasn't an
uninteresting idea it was just less
interesting
um and where would you go first in your
shuffle tardis
i have no idea i see that this is why i
couldn't be the doctor i could be the
companion i would want the doctor to
make that decision i would i have a hard
enough time like when people when
friends ask me where do you want to go
to eat i'm like
could you just decide i'll find
something i want to eat
new mug
if anyone didn't notice liz got me this
um have you ever heard of the anime the
promised neverland nope i am unfamiliar
so
uh
raya c thank you very much i enjoyed
your video about trauma and villain
making as a social work student i find
the trope overplayed and disappointing
yeah
i mean like that's
generally whenever i
whenever i talk about and pick apart
tropes my issue is not that the trope is
inherently bad it's that it's overused
that's the nature of most tropes
uh question
have you heard that they're doing a ruby
justice league animated film based off
the comic of the same name i did hear
that i keep forgetting that that is i
why
why
i think it's because warner brothers
owns rooster teeth
i could be wrong about that
thoughts on the fact that uh we're
getting good omens season two um
i'm not as devoid of hope as i might
otherwise be knowing that there were
actually notes from gaiman and terry
pratchett about ideas that didn't get
used in the first book or um
you know a potential sequel that they
never got around to so it does it helps
that there is some pratchett material
for them to base it off of so i'm less
cynical than i might otherwise have been
i am a little nervous though favorite
tim burton movie uh
[Music]
probably beetlejuice
supreme omega thank you once more i'm
gonna try and wrap it up soon here folks
thoughts on the working class golden age
superman
i would like to get back to that i mean
people forget superman initially was
busting up
slumbords
you know
give me socialist superman back
i feel like you misunderstood my middle
question a little bit i was asking if
you think straight zoomers and
millennials would be willing to to take
to defend queer people
um
more so than gen x there's definitely
more so than boomers i think gen z is
the one that is gonna have the least um
the least craps to give
uh and be the most inclined to just
wreck shop
i think that
i think that there is
more acceptance and love for queer
people amongst the straight population
of my generation
and uh and the generation younger than
me
than probably most
germans had for the jews i i mean i'm
i'm being insanely broad i have to be i
wasn't there
but the impression i get was that the
drew the jews weren't really loved they
were tolerated and i think that is how
the boomer generation feels about queer
people they tolerate us
i think i look around my own generation
and i'm an elder millennial and i see
more
outright love for queer people and i
look at gen z and i see a lot of love
for queer people
and
i think that has the power to
potentially
spur them to action where simple
tolerance would not have done so
um who do you think would win in a
battle uh with an army of droids led by
general grievous or an army of daleks
led by davorus okay first of all those
battle droids were
useless
absolutely useless general grievous no
it wouldn't stand a chance
ah
not a chance even with the super battle
droids not a chance
just notice the earrings oh thank you a
friend of mine gave me this jasper gave
me
these um
have a nice night yes it is about time
for me to wrap it up uh would you say
the 13th doctor is the most psychotic
given her lack of any care when she
actually does dark things
no no i wouldn't because to me
to me psychotic is
to me psychotic is someone who makes a
very deliberate choice to not care
um
as opposed to and like i'm talking i'm
talking narratively i'm not talking
about
you know medical diagnosis i'm not a
psychiatrist
but
i think
the dot i think the 13th doctor
often reads neurodivergent
and is often bad at picking up at
emotional and social cues
and
i would be very cautious
about labeling that as psychotic
because
amongst the people who really like the
13th doctor are a lot of neurodivergent
people
who see a lot of themselves in her
so
just
just be
cautious
about word choice there
i know you didn't mean anything by just
saying all right owl house stage musical
idea
for the actress playing amity
auditioning with corner of the sky and
the actress playing loose auditioning
with extraordinary okay
i'm gonna wrap it up there what time is
it where i am it's it's about 8 10 in
the evening so i'm gonna wrap it up
there thank you all so very much for
joining me i hope you have a great rest
of the week so
um
tomorrow
tomorrow two things happen
um i'll be on twitch at 10 30 am to um
eastern daylight time tomorrow
i'm gonna play a bit more i might wrap
up
spirit fairer which means i'll probably
be crying on stream so that'll be on
twitch
and also at one o'clock tomorrow
afternoon on the vera wild channel
wildspell w-y-l-d-e
i will be premiering a video about
content creators who
got their followings through mainstream
means like tik tok instagram youtube
twitch etc
and then moved on to creating only fans
content it has interviews with six
different creators that's the thing that
i mentioned earlier that i have been
working on editing since
february
it's like it's a freaking documentary
it's an it's an hour and 22 minutes long
i made a movie and it's premiering
tomorrow at 1 00 p.m eastern daylight
time on the vero wild channel
i haven't done a premiere there i think
ever
and i hope people will turn out to to
see it and show support on it so that is
what is coming up in the immediate sense
and for right now
just please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
mccabe